I'm here to tell you to talk about
styling component based systems I work
on a project called spectrum which is a
platform for online communities if you
imagine a mixture between slack and a
forum I made it because I needed a place
for my open source projects communities
to go and there wasn't really a good
solution so that's what spectrum comes
from I want to start by telling you a
little story in October 2016 I was on
the other side of the planet in
Australia and I was there for some
friends and I went out with a friend of
mine called Sharkey and he showed me
this really shady hidden whisky bar
which apparently serves some of the best
whisky in the world it's called uncle
Ming's I think and so you go down into
this this stare unmarked stairwell and
then you go through great curtains and
into this really dark cellar room and
there's a bar and they sell you really
good Chinese food like dumplings and
tempura and some of the best whiskey you
can get on the planet apparently I have
no idea about whiskey so I just went
with Sharkey there and then Sharkey said
another friend of mine is also coming
into whisky and I said well that's
that's nice and then eventually that
friend came and that friend was Glen
matter if you know Glen he's one of the
creators of CSS modules and I'd never
met Glen before and of course him being
the creator of CSS modules I started
talking to him about CSS obviously
because what else do you talk to him
about right uh-hum and the thing was
that at the time the company I was at we
were building this component library
with react called elemental UI but the
problem was that we built it with less
which meant that anybody who used that
component library had to also have less
configured right because we shipped less
files and you had to compile them
somehow so that was not very ideal
because we wanted people to just be able
to use our button we didn't want them to
have to add web pack to the set up if
they weren't using it we didn't want
them to have to add the less Llodra to
set up if they didn't want to use less
right that didn't make any sense and so
we've been thinking about this problem
for a while but hadn't really arrived at
a good solution
of that we wanted the components to be
re skinnable right we wanted people to
be able to quickly just change the
entire color scheme for example to make
it fit their application that also
wasn't possible because even though we
used less variables throughout the
entire CSS people who you who npm
installed that component library
couldn't change those variables right
they were hard-coded in our own files
and they couldn't really change them
unless they've ended it in which nobody
ever did because that's annoying and so
we've been thinking about this problem
for a while and I told talk to Glenn
about it and Glenn said well have you
heard about this thing called CSS and
JavaScript and we didn't tell discussed
using CSS in JavaScript for a bit but it
wasn't very appealing just sounds like
the stupidest idea I've ever heard
honestly like who would put CSS into
JavaScript but those are two separate
languages why would you ever do that
that's what I get class for ah of course
of course but when you think about it it
would make everything much easier
because you can publish CSS in
JavaScript to NPM and when people use
our button they don't have to care about
how specifically to include our CSS into
their setup right system takes care of
injecting it automatically so that was
great and on top of that it's dynamic so
theoretically we should easily be able
to add theming to our components that
could be changed at runtime if people
wanted to the problem was that none of
the existing libraries that did CSS in
JavaScript were great and I don't mean
to put those people down because there
were that there was a ton of
experimentation going on and the people
who built those libraries did a really
good job just don't fit our own needs
right they all let you write CSS as
JavaScript objects which I hate that
honestly I don't want to my CSS
JavaScript objects I like CSS I like
writing CSS I don't want to force that
into JavaScript it doesn't make any
sense but so Glenn and I talked about it
and we arrived at the conclusion that
probably CSS in JavaScript is the way to
go for that because we really wanted to
be able to be shareable with everybody
who wanted to use our component library
and we also really needed theming and
then we talked a bit more about
components right and components
they they have this really interesting
property of hiding implementation
details and I want to explain see what I
mean with that right if you imagine a
button component now this is using
reactant X but it could be any component
JavaScript framework you want to use
right if you have a button component
there's really there could be any number
of states your button component could be
right in our case for example we could
have 3 your standard button a primary
button because sometimes you need a
bigger button because something is more
important and the disabled button right
and as you can see those states of our
component change the HTML that is
generated right if you want to make it
disabled you have to set the type to
disabled because otherwise people could
still click on it and if you always have
to change the class name so that it
looks bigger or it looks disabled and
this is using BEM syntax but again that
could be any class name you want it but
if you think about it in the component
based systems all of those attributes
the class names and the types they're
really implementation details right the
only person they're important for is the
creator of the component if you create a
button component you have to worry about
which specific type does that button tag
have you know which label does it have
how do people pass it text which class
name doesn't have but once you made that
component and people can use it you've
really looks more like this right you
just render a button a primary button or
a disabled button as the user of a
component you don't actually care which
specific class names it attaches you
don't actually care which type is
attaches right I just want to have a
disabled button and that should do the
right thing by default I shouldn't have
to worry about it as the user of a
component in the react community that
led to a in an interesting development
because people started using components
that were solely for styling that didn't
do anything except basically wrap around
a tag with a class name these are
sometimes referred to style components
but there's really no name for that
pattern no standardised name for that
pattern what I mean is if you think
about a grid system right traditionally
you'd have a div class name equals row
and then you would have a div class name
equals call that
five for example he wanted to have five
columns and you would use these class
names throughout your application so
people in the react meeting we
especially in our project started doing
is wrapping these thieves in their own
components so suddenly you had a row
component and you had a column component
and you would use those components
throughout your app the benefit of that
is that you could change the
implementation at any point right I
could switch from floats to flexbox to
CSS grid without the users of the
component ever having to know that I
even switched right they wouldn't care
because they are still just rendering
rows and columns they don't care what
that class name does which class name it
applies they don't care if they don't
have to care about any of that
they just render a row and some columns
and that's it so Glen I talked about all
of these things and we talked about you
know CSS modules and CSS and JavaScript
and we realized that maybe just maybe it
makes sense to always do styling at the
component level and that was really the
first big breakthrough we had right the
first time we both went wait a second we
could do things differently right there
could be a different way of doing things
so we thought about how could we make
that work right where do we where do we
go from there how do you move styling to
the component level what does that even
mean
and so we the next day we sit next to
each other in a shared office and just
how our laptops open and typed out
possibly API is for this library we're
gonna maybe create to potentially write
and what we arrive that sort of a first
idea would look something like this you
said comes component equals element --iv
and then somehow you were gonna add
styles right nobody I we didn't know
what that looked like it but essentially
you would always find your styles to a
Dom node and then reuse that component
throughout your application like a grid
component for example render a div with
some a-callin component will render a
thief with some Styles that made it a
column or a role component for example
then we started thinking about this this
thing of putting styles into JavaScript
because we really didn't want to write
styles as JavaScript or
that was just extremely unappealing to
us we had designers who knew how to
write CSS and we didn't want to have to
teach them JavaScript just to do the
things they've been doing for years
already right they know how to CSS they
know how to write CSS so the second big
breakthrough we had is that we figure
out what if we put actual CSS into
JavaScript what if we let people write
actual CSS like they're used to in
JavaScript and what that looked like
initially was something like this right
you said cons component equals LM div
and then some styles and what that would
generate is a component that when
rendered renders a div tag with the
Styles color blue attached now it's
important to note that we didn't attach
this as inline Styles CSS in JavaScript
has nothing to do with inline styles
instead what we do is we take that
string of CSS and we inject it in a
style tag in the head of the DOM that
means theoretically you would be able to
use media queries pseudo selectors
pseudo elements everything CSS does this
does - at least that was the plan and so
we this is pretty much where we ended
the first day right we have this sort of
API and Glenn said I'm gonna go home and
overnight I'm gonna hack up a first
prototype and see if we can make it work
in the next day he came back and he
showed me an API that looked like this
right and this was sort of a small
synthetic difference right if you think
about it the syntax is almost the same
between those two versions the important
difference is that this is using tag
template literals now tag template
literals were introduced into JavaScript
in es2015 so there are very new
JavaScript feature but essentially those
backticks that you see are just calling
another function right so those are like
any function you call you can also call
with backticks and there's some
differences in how the function who
receives the string actually can handle
the arguments which was very important
for the next point which is that we
realized we could use functions for
conditional styling now that wasn't
obvious because in the first API in this
API if you were to put a function into
this template string that function would
get string if ID and suddenly you in the
middle of your CSS you would have a
literal
action right just a JavaScript college
which is totally useless but like who
needs that anyway that's totally useless
but the the nice thing about tag
template literals is that if you put a
function in here that function we
actually get that function and we can
call it which means we can do this where
we pass you the properties in that
function and then you can change your
styling based on the properties pass
through the component right so what you
see here is a component that renders a
div which has a color of blue if the
primary property is set and a color of
red if the primary property isn't set
and suddenly you could you could do
whatever you wanted new CSS really
depending on the properties right which
is something we needed for our button
component and so this is the story of
where styled components comes from
that's what we eventually called this
library that came from this week of
bashing our heads against each other and
messing with JavaScript the important
point really is the big differential
that made it different and to us easier
to use was the removal of the mapping
between styles and components if you
think about it a class name is a mapping
of a piece of styling to Dom node and
it's a many to many mapping any Dom node
can have many class names and any class
name can be applied on many Dom nodes
right so it's in many of many mapping
between styles and components but as a
developer when you're creating a
component the only time you ever use a
class name is in that component and then
you reuse that component if you have a
button component you only ever write
that button class name once and then you
use that button component throughout
your entire application so if you have a
mapping that used to be many to many and
still is to the dorm a to many but for
the developer is really one to one why
do you have that mapping at all right
there's no need to have a mapping that's
one to one you can just bind them
together so this is what style
components looks like today the import
style from style components and then you
say cons title equals style h1 and then
attack tempered literal now this style
dot h1 call generates a component that
renders an h1 Dom tag and that h1 Dom
tag has a class name that has these
Styles applied
so in this case our title component will
have a font size of 1.5 mm we'd be lying
to the center and we'll have a color of
pale valid red and then we have a second
component here which is a wrapper
component which renders a section tag
that's that's a hundred percent width
and height has some padding is and has a
papaya web background
these are react components in this case
right so these react components I can
just take and use like any other react
component if you've ever used react
these can be used like any other react
component you've ever seen right you're
just right wrapper and title in your JSX
and when you look at this in your
browser you get a section that has a
papaya with background and this width
and height 100% and a title that's
centered and has a color of pale violet
red so here we've really removed the
mapping for developers between styling
and components and instead of reusing
class names throughout the application
you're reusing components throughout
your application as you can see you can
write actual CSS and I mean actual
actual CSS right this string that you
pass us is taken parsed and then inject
it into a style tag in the head of the
DOM that means whatever CSS feature you
want to use you can use it's just CSS
there's nothing special about it right
you're still just using CSS so you could
have a color changer component right
that by default has a background of
papaya whip and a heading inside has a
color of pale violet red and then above
a certain width with a media query you
have a background of medium C green and
the h2 has instead a color of papaya
with now there's this is not some hack
or anything this is actual CSS and you
can write whatever CSS you want if we
open this color changer component in our
browser and we resize the browser what
you see it what you'll see is that it
changes color whoo CSS media queries
yeah
I know we've all seen this before but
the point here is really that it's
actual CSS whatever CSS you know you can
use we don't restrict anything we don't
have to restrict anything because it's
just CSS right there's nothing special
about it it's this CSS you know and love
and then comes the adapting based on
props part right as I said we had this
button component earlier where you have
a normal button and you want to have a
primary button in this case right you
want to have a standard button and then
a more important button for the
important buttons whatever that means
and with style components I can do that
right I can change my background color
and my color based on the property that
is passed to the component so in this
case our button will have a background
of pale pale violet rather than the
color of white if its primary and a
color and then it's inverted if it's not
primary right so if we render a primary
button in a normal button what that
looks like in the browser is that you
have a normal button and a primary
button who would have thought you know
but it's important because this allows
us to create API component api's that
are very natural to react at least in
this case passing a primary pop to
button is pretty standard right and as
the user of the component again I don't
have to care what that button does when
I say it's primary or when I say it's
not primary I don't have to care at all
in this case it's using styled
components functional interpolations to
change the styling a bit but it could
just as well do any number of other
things right and then came our sort of
last big feature that we wanted to add
which is theming and we realized that we
could do theming based on reacts context
feature so if you've ever used Redux
Redux passes state through the component
context and when you connect the
component that connection takes your
theme from the context and inject it
into the component we do the exact same
thing except rather than providing you
state we provide you with a theme so you
can import this theme provide a
component and you can define your theme
and that can be anything you want right
it doesn't matter what that steam says
that's totally up to you you have full
freedom there in our case we're just
going to say that our primary color is
pale violet
and then you wrap either your entire app
or smaller parts of your app in a theme
provider that provides the app with that
theme and then in our button what we can
do is we can say we on our background to
be whatever the primary theme color is
right make sense we're just taking that
from the props saying pop star themes
are primary whatever theme is Pro is
provided to the button that will be its
background color so when we look at this
in a browser of course it's gonna have a
pale valid red background color because
that's our primary color in our theme
but then you can also have multiple
themes right let's say you have a
sidebar and a main app and you want them
to look different so in our case we're
gonna have a red theme and a blue theme
that for some reason makes things green
I just realized that is a green theme so
we have a green female a red theme
ignore that that says blue and then
we're going to wrap different parts of
our app in different themes right so one
part of our app will be in the red theme
and one part of our app will be in the
blue theme and then when we render that
button those two buttons in the browser
you'll see that one is red and one is
green again this is not like
mind-bendingly awesome but if you think
about the implication my button
declaration didn't have to change at all
I didn't have to tell my button manually
that hey you're in a green area you're
in a red area change your color no it
just happens automatically depending on
where that button is rendered right this
works because it uses react context
feature this works as many levels of
components deep as you want right you
could have a div and another component
and another tape and another component
and you can have as many layers of
components as you want and that button
will still be red if there's somewhere
up the tree a red theme provider and
this really meant that people could reef
skin our components at moment's notice
right whenever they needed it if they
wanted to have a dark theme for their
entire app they just swapped their theme
out and that's it and it'll
automatically render with a new theme
now usually at this point people say
well that's cool max but why do you hate
CSS
and I think people must understand the
purpose of style components or all this
exploration around CSS NGS in general
right because CSS is a great language
I love CSS it's an extremely high
problem that is great quote by a man
named Keith who quoted when he who said
when he code CSS you're writing abstract
rules to take unknown content and
organize it in an unknown medium that
[ __ ] is hard
CSS solves an extremely high problem in
an extremely elegant way for spectrum
for example users we let users post
posts right and they can write comments
to those posts so the very standard
thing but if you even think about what
how many different things could people
write in those posts and in those
comments there's infinite combinations
of characters and emojis and images that
they could put into those posts and
comments and yet I just have to write
five lines of CSS and it'll all look
good hopefully and also that same
content can be rendered on I don't know
how many millions of difference of
devices we have by now how many
different laptops and mobile phones and
watches and what-have-you that websites
are rendered on right this problem is an
extremely hard one take arbitrary
content in an arbitrary medium and make
it look good that's an extremely high
problem and CSS solves it extremely well
and style components isn't meant to say
hey CSS is [ __ ] we're gonna do this
better not at all right all we're doing
is taking CSS and making it work even
better for our use case right which for
us was a component system we needed CSS
to work well in a component system and
we wanted to take the overhead out for
human developers right we didn't want
our developers to have to worry about
which specific class name is used where
and to avoid naming collisions and all
of that we just wanted our developers to
be able to write their components have
it be mobile and have it easily be
shareable on NPM and that's really where
style components comes from it's not
trying to replace your says it's trying
to enhance it and make it work for our
use case thank you very much that's it
that's all I've got today but I've also
got a ton of stickers which I put on the
slides so I don't forget to say that so
if you want stickers just come find out
come find me afterwards
listen thank you
[Applause]